voilà il est arrivé alain juppé leur
confiance j'éprouve des sentiments de
profonde reconnaissance envers tous même
si le résultat n'est évidemment pas à la
hauteur de mes espérances
je termine cette campagne comme je les
ai commencé en homme libre qui n'aura
transiger ni avec ceux qui les nient
avec ce qu'il pense
je félicite françois fillon pour sa
large victoire la primaire de la droite
s'est déroulée dans deux du centre s'est
déroulée dans de bonnes conditions grâce
à la haute autorité et au comité
d'organisation que je salue et comme je
m'y étais engagé j'apporte dès ce soir
mon soutien à françois fillon je lui
souhaite bonne chance pour sa prochaine
campagne présidentielle et la victoire
en mai prochain
quant à moi je vais me consacrer
pleinement à ma tâche de maire de
bordeaux qui m'a donné et me donne tant
de joie et je remercie particulièrement
les bordelaises et les bordelais qui
montrent à nouveau témoigné leur
confiance est largement aujourd'hui je
veux aussi remercier du fond du coeur
toutes celles et tous ceux qui m'ont
soutenu depuis le début de cette belle
compagne toute empreinte de dignité
toutes celles et ceux qui m'ont rejoint
et accompagner jusqu'à aujourd'hui et
qui sont là effectivement et le dise
d'abord
d'abord tous les français qui monte
accueillis dans tous les territoires de
la république les parlementaires les
élus locaux les maires si nombreux
qu'ils m'ont reconnu comme l'un des
leurs mais comité de soutien aussi
exemplaire depuis des mois certains
membres dans des partis de la droite et
du centre
elle est rude et au modem ou engagés
pour la première fois dans la vie
politique
les jeunes avec juppé vient chez
et maintenant et maintenant et
maintenant et maintenant et maintenant à
vous de continuer à vous jeunes
françaises et français tout
particulièrement à qui l'avenir
appartient continuer sur le chemin que
nous avons tracée dans cette campagne
pleine de dignité je les dis mais aussi
d' enthousiasme continuer à porter
l'idée de la france que nous avons
partagé une france apaisée et
réconcilier pour un pc il faut rassurer
pour assurer il faut être fort
soyez forts pour réarmer l'état et pour
reconstruire une économie plein emploi
mais pour apaiser et réconciliée il faut
aussi donner une espérance
il faut mettre sa force au service de la
générosité du respect mutuel de la
justice je sais que c'est l'esprit qui
vous anime
continuez enfin à construire une france
toute entière tournée vers l'avenir
optimiste accueillante aux progrès
travailler à redonner un sens à l'europe
et pour cela tendait la main aux jeunes
européens
vos frères engagez vous
engagez vous pour changer notre façon de
vivre
de sorte qu'elle soit davantage en
harmonie avec cette terre qui nous porte
restez vigilants pour mettre les
révolutions scientifiques et techniques
qui vont s'accélérer au service de
l'homme la seule cause qui vaille
j'ai donné j'ai donné quarante ans de ma
vie au service de la france et cela m'a
apporté de grands bonheurs et quelques
paires ce soir encore au risque de vous
surprendre je dirais que je suis heureux
d'avoir parlé en français tout au long
de cette magnifique compagne pour leur
dire ce que je crois la tâche qui vous
attend est exaltante
vous avez de la chance je vous souhaite
bonne chance et je souhaite par dessus
tout bonne chance à la france